the ground shook it felt like the bombs
were landing on top of us
the shelling landed so close we had to
lie on the ground when you see your
house burning you can only thank God to
cut out safely with your children all
over things were burned and stolen but
the fact that your life is enough good
things can be replaced but not your life
since the fighting is started my husband
hasn't been able to visit us he's a
soldier as the rebels
[Music]
no manager for what the garden must mean
the hardest thing now is to find food
and soap my heart aches when I see other
women taking care of their children in
their homes while mine are displays
stay the whole day caves when the
Antonov planes fly overhead
[Music]
no was it honor would be if he just sit
there and ask God for something will he
help you no you have to act and work
hard and God will give you what you need
[Music]
when my children grow up they must
become soldiers to fight for their
rights if there is peace then my
children will be educated
[Music]